Sáng nay ngày 18 tháng 6 năm 2018, Israel đã tính thành của Khong Kích Môn lớn,
nhằm vào hàng trục mục tiêu chế khắp i ra, bao gồm các cơ sở quân sự và hạt nhân.
Như tiến lộ đã được vi nhận tại thủ đô T-Ran, trong khi hệ thống kỏi bảo động vang lý khắp i Israel.
Bộ trường Quốc phòng Israel sắp nhận nước này đã phát động cuộc tấn công phủ đô vào i ra.
Theo CNN, các cuộc tấn công này khu phải là hành động trong bộ ngày,
mà là vình đầu tiên trong một chiến dịch bức sự kéo dài, có mục tiêu gió giá.
Bộ trường Quốc phòng Israel cũng đã tính bộ tình trạm cấp tận quốc,
theo đó, ngày từ rằng Sáng nay, Israel đã cấp tổng tổng bộ các hạt động tủ tập.
Học tập vào làm việc và chiến dịch sử thiết yêu,
đông thư kính bảo khả năng Iran sẽ sớm đáp trả vang tư lượng và thiết định mai không người lại.
Đăng chú ý, của Khong Kích được cho là đá khiến tưởng hoa sêng xa làm gì,
tổng tư lệnh lượng lượng bị bình cách mạng hồi giao Iran thiệt mạc.
Đây là một trong những những vật quy lực nhất trong quân độ Iran,
và là biểu tượng của sự cưng gián trước các áp được Quốc ấy.
Như háu chuyến thông nghề nước Iran đã sớm nhận thông tin này,
dù việc tệ Iran chưa được giá tư bộ chính thức.